this time
it flashed through my mind that he might
not make it
keep breathing
i can't think of a worse situation that
he could have gotten himself in three
two one
at any second the shark can become
aggressive
then you are definitely shark food
beneath 12 000 square miles of rugged
wilderness
hides the highest concentration of caves
in north america i always really crave
the wild places
places where you don't see any trace of
human beings
places like cascade cave
and no one's been in here in a while
a place so secretive you need a key to
get inside
andrew munoz leads a mission to reach
the bottom of this one-mile network
his head cam records the journey
if i had
any idea that we were gonna go through
what we went through i wouldn't have
use the gone if you want are you the
wolf
really good right there
andrew's friend and former boss jason
story is the rookie of the group
this is just his fifth time caving
show me what i'm doing
so i think we'll just get you to find
the wall and we'll just have this on as
your backup yeah i'll do some back
pressure and it'll just feed on its own
okay
yeah
yeah
okay and then do you remember how to get
this thing off
i'll figure it out
zach zariske brings up the rear
i hadn't met jason before actually until
the day of the trip
we kind of hit it off in the aspect that
he liked to cave i liked the cave he
liked rock climb i liked rock climbing
[Music]
zach can you bring that bag over
four hours later they're nearly at the
bottom of cascade cave
above ground a ferocious storm hits the
island
dumping a trillion gallons of rain
ice cold water rushes into the cave
so basically just one good foot spike
and just doing a big press over the top
there
there was a lot of water we had
overextended ourselves and we were
at very great risk
the team must get out and fast
jason goes first
it's not super solid so don't bump me
okay good yeah i'm better now
and just remember when you get up there
i'll pass you the rope up
so take this one up here
somewhere turn around the other way this
one on that side
the first stage is a 12 foot vertical
climb
then they face the notorious bastards
crawl
this 20-foot long corridor tapers into a
choke point
only inches wide
it's the only way out
and then head burst
i knew it was gonna be a challenge
i was worried that someone was gonna
have trouble with the climb
i'm worried about zach i'm worried about
myself there is a very small space to
get through without getting into the
flow of the water
as zach waits for jason to squeeze
through bastard's crawl
the narrow passage fills with frigid
water
okay okay just relax just relax gage
okay you want to back out eddie just
chill out just relax man it's all good
he was stuck in the absolute tightest
part with six to eight inches of space
between the water and the
we're roof there
okay
good you're in the air
you're in the air don't make any fast
moves okay dad
where are your feet can you move your
feet
you're all good okay
he was stuck in the flow of the water
right up to his neck and he couldn't
move one hand out here
okay one hand on that side yeah you got
good you got good hands
you got good hands yeah
dude you got some hands yes okay
okay
you're on it
you're on the other side where's that
foot okay push up feet
push on me yeah okay
you have something
and i want you to put your feet up put
your feet on me okay
feel free
keep coming
okay keep it up you got a good hand
okay
slowly this way okay
i knew that i had just a couple of
minutes to try and help him
to the side
solid
he's at risk of drowning within the next
couple of minutes
keep killing you
keep coming
i feel
completely helpless and out of control
keep breathing hands out
i was worried that i was going to watch
this person die in front of me
because
come on jake
come on dude
come on junior
hands out it's still breathing okay
can't touch to the side
speed up
come towards me
come this way
clean up
towards me
head up
head up hands down
okay
lift your ass up and float
lift your ass up
and
go shake
come on
okay keep breathing
there you're there okay
dude
shake
look at me okay you made it all right
yeah i'm scared you made it okay
let's chill out for a second okay
i need you to crawl that way all right
two seconds okay
i need you to start moving jake
i need you to start moving okay my legs
it's all right dude we're gonna get out
of here all right
he was exhausted trying to fight the
water i need to come up with a plan to
get him out
jason is stuck near the entrance of
bastard's crawl
trapping andrew and zach in the base of
the cave
i need you to climb that way okay
just relax man we're going to do this
together okay
i know you are dude i know you're i
think we had a bit more water
we might have had a football come down
okay okay we're gonna do this together
dude i'm gonna make you a loop out of
this rope with the standing okay i'm
gonna hook it up here and then that's
gonna give you something to push on okay
don't fight him
i'm trying to stay
positive in the message that i'm giving
to him
i'm trying to offer
active solutions to get him out of the
water
here
finally jason's foot is free
we're gonna take a breather
we're gonna assess the water situation
jason has been submerged in ice cold
water for eight minutes
i thought how can he not be shivering he
must be freezing i'm shivering and then
i think right
he's progressed past shivering
that's because jason has hypothermia his
body is shutting down
jason's heart has slowed to conserve
energy restricting blood flow to his
vital organs
unchecked
the cold could kill him
we had no time to waste to getting him
out
or he was gonna
die a winter storm batters vancouver
island flooding a cave system
okay okay just relax just relax
trapping three friends deep underground
jason's story survives drowning barely
but is suffering from hypothermia and
fighting for his life
i know that i need to raise the
temperature we don't have a lot of
equipment with us and we needed to
improvise some solutions based on what
you have
andrew has a portable stove
he heats the freezing water
and showers jason in it
he started shivering after one or two
applications of hot water and that gave
me a big sense of relief
it meant that his brain hadn't been
damaged
jason will die without medical help
but this deep underground there's no way
to reach 9-1-1 it was pretty obvious
that jay's situation wasn't getting any
better without some help
it's up to zach to make the mile long
climb alone
and call for a rescue
andrew and jason must wait
to conserve battery power
the lights and camera go out
they are alone
in the dark
one mile underground
i'll never forget
the ever-present roar of the water
how it rings inside your skull and
vibrates your whole body to the point
where you would give anything
to shut that sound off
ten
maddening hours pass
the mind goes to some
incredibly dark places
when you are truly trapped
my daughter was
still very young
i had so much guilt
and fear
that she'd grow up without a dad because
he decided to go caving one weekend and
made some bad decisions that
i battled a lot
with
whether i needed to make a message for
her
add the camera
i had nothing but time
but
to me that's
giving up completely
the storm
eases
the sound started to diminish ever so
slightly at first i was like is it
getting quieter is that water
slowing it has to be
andrew realizes there's an opportunity
to escape the cave
despite his condition jason won't be
left behind
he said i'm gonna do it let's go
our bodies were
so broken by that point
that it took
every ounce
to make an inch
and again and again
and all of a sudden you're through
we're there
and we are ecstatic
elated beyond belief
right from the point where we made it
through bastard's crawl i was flying
high i was on cloud nine i was we've
made it out of this cave was was how i
felt
andrew and jason have traveled no more
than 20 feet
there's still a grueling mile long climb
between them and safety jason's physical
condition was really bad he was having
to pick up his own feet
with his hands and put them on
footholds and then summon each move
almost like a power lifter with a big
screen
to move
over and over and over almost 24 hours
after they first entered the cave
they can finally see the exit i could
see lights and hear voices
it's the rescue team
regrouping after a failed attempt to
reach the stranded men
one of the rescuers was a friend and she
was the first to sort of spot our
headlamps and see that we were there and
she shouted down
[Music]
i started to well up with tears
yeah it was just
just a feeling of being overjoyed
okay all team subject is out of the hole
i've been back in cascade uh three times
since
one near-death experience could turn you
fearful of a lot of things but for me
it's made me want to have more
experiences
[Music]
[Applause]
and we're hiking a gnome trail
fell and is injured
he fell fifty to sixty feet
a lot of people don't survive a fall of
that height
the victim is hong bo zhao a 42 year old
local man out to explore cat mountain
with his 15 year old son
pima county search and rescue races to
the
i get this scene here
joining brian on the rescue mission our
pilot pat mackin and winch operator tj
price wearing a head can
time is going to be the the crucial
factor there's potential of him having
life-threatening injuries up there
we got information from the patient that
the sun was above
where he had fallen
we have one person who's in a bad
location and potentially has severe
injuries
we have this son unattended in a
dangerous location
hey brian we're at this uh
i'm sliding to the left
is
it if you want to go to the top of this
rock and climb down or go down you're
gonna have to let me know
bringing you left
bringing him left
is in danger himself the helicopter is
generating powerful winds
that could blow him straight off the
side of the mountain
i felt a lot of fear
and panic
my main worry was my dad i told him like
my dad's down there
he had said he fell 50 or 60 feet and he
definitely had done that
i can't think of a worse situation that
he could have got himself in
in arizona pima county search and rescue
hovers above cat mountain
they must save two victims
fifteen-year-old thomas xiao and his dad
hongbo
who's fallen 60 feet into a narrow
crevice
situated
80 of trauma deaths occur in the first
hour
the clock is ticking
the tucson mountain valley is known for
its intense desert winds which make
flying a helicopter exceptionally
difficult
when the wind hits a mountain it'll go
straight up vertical as you get closer
to the mountain you're starting to feel
those winds
pat wrestles the controls fighting to
keep the chopper steady
[Music]
[Music]
he has a window this big if he goes
anywhere other i'm gonna smash into the
they mountains to get me in this crevice
i have no control
i know that it's now on me i know that i
have to keep it stable i try not to move
because you have a life on that line
get ready
okay
we just gotta get you out okay i'm just
gonna get you out
you're lucky man
yeah wow
i could have got ugly
what's your name
i'll call you sir
it's too dangerous to stay attached to
the helicopter one gust of wind and pat
could lose control
slamming brian into the rocks
i unhook from the cable and i hold the
cable up to let them know that it's free
to come up they had like a a two foot
window
and as i let go the cable swung further
into the crevice
if the cable snags a rock the helicopter
could jackknife and smash into the
cliffs below the heart skips a beat
oh my gosh that cable is going to get
stuck in the rock
[Music]
incredibly the cable scrapes through
how that didn't get caught up in iraq is
beyond me
ryan's now free to examine hunga
it's the hidden injuries that worry him
the most
he had blood on his face with a head
injury if you're bleeding in your brain
that's a critical and something you need
to get to the hospital immediately for
or else you could die
can you put that arm through that hole
you see it
there's not enough space on the ledge to
lower a stretcher in so brian must
attach a body hardness to hongbo a
highly risky maneuver
i need to make sure whatever i do
isn't making him lose his footing and
then fall the rest of the way
i just hovered a distance away
until brian is ready to have us come
back in
station is packaged and ready to go
now it's up to winch operator tj to
guide an unweighted cable directly into
the narrow crevice
[Music]
it was all over the place
i'm looking straight up and i can see
a very small part of the helicopter
they're gonna have to be so precise
but they lower it right into my hand
now we're at the really important stage
we got to get that victim out of there
if the rescue team can get hungo to the
emergency room less than an hour after
his fall he'll be four times more likely
to survive
it is my job to keep it absolutely rock
steady
there's a living human being down below
us and i do not want to injure him
i was trying to prevent him from being
swung into the to the canyon wall
but the swing was too much
and he actually hit the wall
as soon as hunger is clear pat can fly
him directly out of the crevice
45 minutes since he fell and smashed his
head
hungbo is on his way to the hospital
he'll make the one-hour window
but his son and his rescuer remain
stranded and alone and out here there
are no guarantees
brian bowle has just helped rescue an
injured hiker from the top of a remote
peak
now
he's stuck
in the same spot i'm gonna need to be
hoisted that was definitely uh what we
call cliffed out i can't go up or down
trapped above him on the edge of the
crevice
is the victim's teenage son
are you able to hike out or no
it's too steep
okay
30 minutes after rescuing hongbo the
team is back
i look down a few feet in the crevice
hopefully give you a bigger window
i'm just going to sit here and let you
bring the hook to me
once i got hooked in they were able to
fly out of the crevice
[Music]
the job's not done
the victim's 15 year old son is still in
danger of falling to his death i don't
want to get real close to him because i
don't want my rotor wash blowing him
around because he's still on the top of
a cliff the crevice was right there
where his dad has just felt
pat drops brian a safe distance from the
teenager
they can't rush this
at this point everything for me is now
very slow i can go as slow as i need to
go to make sure everything is is done
safely
that was a pretty nasty fall dude
i could see some some nervousness in his
eyes
he was trying to be brave
having the last person that needs to be
rescued off the mountain is always a
calming feeling
just over an hour after the 9-1-1 call
came in
everyone is finally safe
scans reveal hungo has multiple injuries
including spinal fractures and two
bleeds on the brain
but thanks to pima county sheriff's
department
he eventually makes a full recovery
and is still hiking with his son
i think i'm just um
overwhelmed by the joy but the relief
i'm just feeling so happy that i'm alive
off the coast of new south wales is nine
mile reef
it's a magnet for spear fishermen
when you're spearfishing it's like
hunting but you're as far out of your
element and comfort zone as you possibly
can get
i just love the ocean my first time
diving seeing trev slap some big fish
down on the deck
and i was like this is awesome so
got the bug early and i haven't stopped
but they aren't the only predators here
it's known to the locals as a sharky
spot
yes
films on a head cam as he spearfishes
with his friend dylan briggs
dylan's dad scott
drives the boat and then the sharks came
in so i just ran my hand again she
started swimming up
like let's get this to the top
are you going to hurt us
dylan started diving over five years ago
trev taught him everything because
that's trev's passion
[Music]
by the time they resurface underwater
currents have carried dylan and trevor
over a hundred feet away from the boat
your responsibility as a driver is to
make sure that the people in the water
are safe
that they can get to the boat
in the boat above scott must estimate
where trevor and dylan will emerge
they're in the drink i've got my eyes on
them one of them goes down while the old
guy stays up
sometimes they both go down together
they're down there for a minute and a
half
it's been a good day so far the boys
have already caught three fish
but the conditions are shifting
the winds picked up to 25 knots the
swells picked up
they dive once
more when i drove to where i thought
they were or should be
they weren't
i started to panic
because i should have had them in the
boat within three minutes
scott knows they can't hold their breath
for this long i'm traveling upstream
driving me bow
up doing these big ass bands and
scouring the
area scott frantically widens his search
area unaware he's losing his bearings i
was driving around madly after him
they couldn't have gone this far
after 10 minutes
he fears the worst
i thought they'd been taken because
there's big sharks out there i thought
their life was over that's it i've lost
my son and my son's best mate
dylan briggs and trevor ketchum have
disappeared in the pacific ocean
dylan's dad searches frantically but
can't find them anywhere they went down
and
that was the last i've seen
but dylan and trevor have surfaced
the five mile an hour currents on the
reef have dragged them 150 feet away
from where they first dive down
dad scott has lost his bearings and is
heading in the wrong direction
i was looking around to see where the
boat was and he wasn't there
[Music]
we could just see him
bobbling over like the swell maybe three
or four hundred meters away
[Applause]
we were waving our guns and fins in the
air and trying to get his attention
but he couldn't see us because of the
waves
[Music]
[Music]
if staying afloat and trying to reach
don's dad isn't enough all their
movement
is attracting sharks
at any second the shark can turn and
become aggressive
then you are definitely shark food
they were coming in and then they turned
it last minute
it was scary
the sharks
begin to disperse
but by now
scott is even further away
looking in the wrong direction we
realized that he's driving away from us
they decide to swim towards the boat so
scott can see them
i jumped straight on the radio i've lost
them
10 minutes ago i've lost them i need
somebody out here now get somebody
out here
from 70 miles away aircrew officer tim
sharman's helicopter rescue team
responds to the call
two people had gone missing in a vast
ocean in deep water
no one was exactly sure where these
individuals may be okay so habit
security is good advice when speeds
below 80 and we are clear doors
tim is one of a four-man crew including
paramedic ryan salter
water jobs are always quite time
critical we don't know someone's injured
we don't know if they've become
separated from each other
it will take the team 25 minutes to fly
to nine mile reef
all the while the current is pulling
trevor and dylan
further away from dylan's frantic dad
i'm not gonna
[Music]
looking for us where he dropped us off
he doesn't understand that current falls
the longer we swim this way
the less chance we haven't getting that
way by that
we can just tread water
we decided to
use what remaining energy we had in
order to swim for land
oh this is going to be a long swim
we'll call him if we get to land
hopefully he finds us or someone does on
the way
the estimate it could take eight hours
to reach shore
four miles away
by now the rescue team closes in on nine
mile reef
we're responding to the location that
these people were last seen
every person in the helicopter needs to
be searching for them
that is the reef
all right so when i was outside these
every second that we're not on scene is
a time that the patients
can move way out to sea all right so
we're all securing the rear cover
they're looking for a black red pudding
black water
tricky they let the hairstyle get lucky
you look out of your window and see a
vast ocean in front of you and you're
expecting not to find anything
what's racing 3 online it's nothing but
disastrous
it's really traumatizing i i was dry
reaching out there
thinking i'm not going to see my son
anymore
[Music]
two divers are lost in the pacific ocean
the search for them has become national
news
the men aged 22 and 27 were on a family
diving trip at nine mile reef this
morning when they went missing the
father of one of the divers raised the
alarm now dylan and trevor are
attempting the daunting four-mile swim
to shore
we were swimming as hard as we could and
we were making no ground at all it does
look like it's getting closer
better i'm hallucinating
not taking much headway disappointed
almost a mile away at nine mile reef
the helicopter team has drawn a blank
if they've been swimming for the whole
time
they're becoming fatigued
it's going to affect their ability to
remain afloat
okay that's an hour and 15 minutes down
yeah nine to go
i started to feel
bad muscle cramps in my legs
when fatigue sets in and you pass out
that's when bad things can happen
[Music]
we had to continue searching but where
to search effectively was crucial for
their survival
the currents have to judge but it's
probably basically the south side of the
reef
so maybe if we do some southern runs
along here
yeah we elected to search following the
current
you could hear the rotor blades of the
helicopters
there was definitely a sense of relief
knowing that someone was out there
looking for us
but the rescue team
doesn't see them
you go way out to sea the water is deep
the water is black someone in the black
wetsuit blends perfectly into the ocean
environment
yeah but we're black on a blue surface
man
it was frustrating to see the
helicopters fly over the top of us
he got angry and he would slap the water
and venting his rage that way
so around here guys eyes out this side
i noticed out of the corner of my eye a
splash
i spotted spotted two divers two divers
three o'clock two divers three o'clock
we had found what we were looking for
did they wave or anything yeah they did
i've lost sight somewhere in this
vicinity one o'clock
make a right turn turn right that is the
worst possible feeling
the rescue team scours the waves below
we should be able to see them and a few
seconds later here we are searching for
them again
the crew combs the area for five minutes
nothing
oh they're there left side at seven
o'clock now see
they turned around they stopped right
above us
yeah they just below us
they were hovering above us
they've they've found us we were stoked
first checks are complete thumbs up
coming off properly
down go down to 50 feet
moving across the cabinet
holding on to the door second chance
hook with connectors harness best
chin strap riser gloves and comp
secretary complete with their right
the ocean is moving the helicopter's
moving the winchman's moving and the
people in the water are moving the risks
are
quite high if done incorrectly
[Applause]
ryan lands within harm's reach of dylan
and he grabbed hold of me and
lifted me up
now safe
news cameras capture the rescue
i seen a black figure coming up and out
of the ocean well that was it
i'm sprawled out in the middle of my
boat
like thanking god
okay
okay everyone is on board the aircraft
as i was in the helicopter and the door
was closed that's
when i had time to actually start
thinking about all the things that could
have gone wrong
and i could have ended up dead
we are very thankful for the rescuers
i just walked straight up to dad and
gave him a big hug always forgiven and
you can't really get angry at someone
for something like that it's just a part
of it
[Music]
you